[Applause]
[Music]
Spain is known as who your glazes
country the land of the flamenco and
high unemployment rates even now and all
of Europe is emerging from the crisis
this country maintains a higher
unemployment rate than Iraq or Albania
in other words Spain isn't exactly a
role model as far as economics is
concerned however there's a region that
doesn't fit at all in this category
yes dear viewer we are talking about the
basque country also known as use katie
along with navarro these are two of the
richest and most prosperous regions in
the entire of spain both of the Basque
Country and Navarre usually at the top
of every indicator far above by the way
Catalonia in other words we could say
that these two regions are something
like a small Germany within Spain with
an entirely different political system
to the rest of the country and a
business sector more typical of northern
Europe than southern Europe moreover
this area has its own language this is
called a scatter unlike Catalan ao
Sierra sounds nothing like Castellon but
that is not all like Catalonia the
Basque Country also has an important
separatist movement in fact ten years
before catalan politicians began to
demand independence for a secured
governments had also tried to become a
sovereign state this was known as the
abara che Plan C prevent presidents of
the Basque Country Boris is officially
called the Basque lehendakari Juan Jose
Eber ah Cheh tried to divorce from Spain
and they went pretty badly much that is
something we are going to address in a
whole other video
[Music]
so let's get on to today's question and
that's why is the Basque Country and
Navarre richer than the rest of Spain
why do we say that they have a different
political system to the rest of the
country well we are going to answer all
of those questions today but before we
do let's dive into the history medieval
heritage both regions the Basque Country
and Navarre
have a special status called the Basque
economic agreements many people think
that this special status came from the
Middle Ages but the truth is that it did
it
see in the year 1200 the ancient kingdom
of Navarre what are now known as the a
larvae biscaia
and keepers queer provinces in navara
itself joins the castile crown as a
condition for this union the Castilian
King had to recognize these so-called
Navarez Queiroz or laws that is to say
that this kingdom would maintain an
independent government with its own laws
its own courts and its own taxes for
example no navara citizen could be
forced to do military service
these Nevarez laws remained practically
unchanged for centuries but don't think
that this is an anomaly every feudal or
absolutist political system be it in
Spain France or the United Kingdom was
full of regions with special rights and
special laws however things changed in
the 19th century
at that time Spain was consolidated as a
modern state and it decided to imitate
the model of Napoleon's France that is a
centrist model
[Music]
but that means that almost every law
would be dictated from the capital and
would apply equally throughout the
territory as you can imagine this did
not please the Neva Ruiz and the Basque
citizens suddenly that's pay more taxes
and do compulsory military service not a
great combination
this explains why during the 19th
century Spain had not one not two but
three civil wars these were these
so-called Carlist Wars where the old
regime supporters mainly Basques and
neva Ruiz fought against the Spanish
army then in 1876 when these Nevarez
Basque troops were defeated the laws
were abolished suddenly these four
provinces had to follow the laws that
came from Madrid in addition they had to
pay a percentage of their taxes to the
central state in return Madrid allowed
them to retain a special fiscal status
and this concession is what we call the
Basque agreement which as you can see
wasn't born in the Middle Ages but was
approved in exchange for abolishing of
the laws but it doesn't end there
decades later in 1939 Franco's
dictatorship eliminated this economic
agreement but only in the two provinces
that didn't support him hooey boosts Goa
and Disgaea as you can really see from
all of this it's a rather torturous
story with Wars and demands from both
sides both provinces which lost their
special fiscal conditions were
especially hurt and this can be seen
today where a huge percentage of Biscay
ins and creepers Cohen's want
independence from Spain and all this
explains why in the 1970s the new
democratic spanish constitutions writers
wanted to combat said basque and Lavar
the basque
agreements returns but this time in a
modernized version
the mask quota this is one of the most
confusing issues in Spanish politics see
if a citizen lives in Malaga or or valid
a lid he or she pays most of their taxes
directly to the central government of
course there are some special taxes that
depends on the city or the autonomous
community but the vast majority goes to
the National Treasury afterward the
state distributes this money among the
different autonomous governments as ever
they see fit
[Music]
these are the so-called autonomic
transfers and of course some regions
tend to benefit from these transfers and
others are harmed in theory and this is
quite debatable the richer regions help
the poorer regions however both Navarre
and the Basque Country have a different
system in this case the provincial
governments collect almost all of the
taxes and notice here that I said
provincial this means that if a citizen
lives for example in bilbao they do not
pay taxes to the basque government but
to the FISC iya provincial council and
this provincial government has the
autonomy to do things like this
this kya will change taxes on company
profits to increase competitiveness so
maybe you remember in another video we
told you why Switzerland is so rich now
one of the reasons for this is that in
Switzerland each can song can compete
with each other by offering better
fiscal conditions while something
similar is happening in the Basque and
the vara provinces and that explains why
taxation in these regions is a little
lower than it is in the rest of Spain
now you may be wondering do these
provincial councils pay nothing to the
Spanish state well no there's none of
that so that's where these so-called
Basque quota comes into play the Basque
quota is the percentage these regions
pay to the central government in
exchange for the common services they
enjoy for belonging to Spain
for example the army embassies and roads
all these are paid by Madrid but the
Basques can also enjoy them they
therefore have to pay part of the cost
and not only that if for example Spain
decided to increase their defense
budgets the basket quota would also grow
proportionally as you can imagine all of
this is theoretical the truth is that
the basket quota is the result of
political negotiations / that's a
different story for a different day the
truth is that unlike all the other
autonomous communities the Basque
Country in navara know exactly how much
money they pay for the common cause and
how much remains and in most cases this
is a fantastic advantage but just wait a
moment because this doesn't end here
[Music]
in principle it might seem that the
economic agreement is a fair system
everything in the negotiation is black
and white but the truth is that the
system is far from perfect jumera when i
said that the central state distributes
the money that it collects among the
different autonomous communities while
the truth is that both navara and the
basque country belong to this
distribution and being such rich regions
it would be logical to think that they
would contribute more than they receive
well
that is totally not happening the basque
country receives twice as many resources
per capita as madrid catalonia or
Andalusia and so now you may be asking
yourself this and that's well how is
this possible
the reason was purely political as I was
saying Basque nationalism is as
important as Catalan nationalism that
means that these autonomous communities
have their own political parties parties
such as the Basque Nationalist Party
which holds its communities government
and has a strong representation in the
national parliament well every year the
central government has to approve
national budgets in Parliament for that
they need an absolute majority the
majority that in most cases requires
support from these parties however this
isn't the only reason for the basque
country's prosperity not at all in fact
there's much more at play here and let's
look into it right now
[Music]
in Germany and Spain have you heard of a
company called Oakley well if you have a
gas stove you might earn some of their
products it's the world leader in
manufacturing systems for preventing
accidents and gas leaks and their
headquarters are in order Zia a town in
the deepest Cova province the same goes
for je ma if you have an armored door in
your house it's highly likely that both
the lock and the keys have been
manufactured by this company which is
located in Mondragon this is a small
basque town these are the so-called
hidden leaders
they are small hyper specialized
companies that have become benchmarks in
their niche and which have devastated
the international markets in a previous
video we told you how Germany owes part
of its wealth to Mittal stance
well the Basque economic model is very
similar moreover if you have the
opportunity to travel by road through
Yeti you'll see factories dispersed
throughout its landscape in fact its
population is much more scattered than
anywhere else in Spain of course there
are large cities but most people live in
urban centres of less than 40,000
inhabitants
and most of these municipalities have
business hubs that employ locals in the
Basque Country economic activity isn't
only concentrated in large cities and
now you may ask yourself well why does
this kadhi have such a homogeneous
business network for this we return to
the same principle and that's
decentralization by having four
different Treasuries with autonomy to
collects taxes and make investments
there's a higher tax competition than in
any other part of Spain
this means that public investments
aren't concentrated in a specific place
that are distributed evenly vesting in
startups will have a 30% deduction in
buscar in other words it's true both the
Basques and the Nevarez
have a huge advantage because they
receive money from the central state but
that money has been invested much more
efficiently than in any other region in
fact it's no coincidence that these two
communities are the least indebted in
all of Spain and that in addition they
have hardly any of the corruption cases
that have poisoned the rest of the
country
[Music]
so now the question is do you think some
elements of the Basques and Navarre ease
models could be rescued and replicated
in other countries do you think it would
be possible to apply the basque
agreements to other regions
well let us know in the comments section
below also as always thank you for
watching and please do leave a like and
do subscribe we have brand new videos
every Monday and Thursday also let me
thank our friends at the reconsider
media podcast they provided the vocals
in this episode that were not mine and
as always thank you for watching
[Music]